[MUSIC PLAYING]
CARTER MORGAN: Let's talk
about Kf, a new tool that
lets you quickly modernize
your Cloud Foundry workloads
and use the same Cloud Foundry
concepts you know and love,
but on Kubernetes.
If you're a platform
owner using Cloud Foundry,
you're not going to
want to miss this video.
Cloud Foundry's easy-to-use
developer workflow
allowed application teams to
almost magically deploy code
to an application infrastructure
they knew nothing about,
and in just a couple of minutes
using a few terminal commands.
But over time, Cloud Foundry as
a platform has become legacy.
Applications evolved.
Microservices exploded.
Customers moved to the
cloud using Kubernetes
as their container orchestrator.
But many of these customers
wanted a familiar, intuitive
developer abstraction
on top of Kubernetes.
So how could you
move to Kubernetes
and maintain that same
developer experience?
That's where Kf comes into play.
Kf provides a smooth
stepping stone
from what you had
before to what's next.
It allows you to
modernize workloads
by running them
on GKE and Anthos,
but what makes Kf special is
that it minimizes developer
downtime by allowing developers
to retain the same Cloud
Foundry workflow
they already use.
So just like in Cloud
Foundry, when you typically
type the cf push command to
build and deploy your code,
you can do the same with
Kf by saying kf push.
So same workflow,
but now instead
of operating three to
four updates behind
because of complex tooling,
you can use up-to-date tooling
and dependencies.
You get the advantages of
integrating new updates
quickly.
And once you're on the cloud,
it becomes a lot simpler
to try different managed
or unmanaged products.
You see, at its core, Kf
is an abstraction layer
that makes it easier
for applications
to run on Kubernetes,
GKE, or even Anthos.
Kf becomes your
bridge to the cloud,
providing an easy process
for modernizing workloads.
Not only that, once
you're using Google Cloud,
billing becomes straightforward
and costs get significantly
reduced because Google Cloud
understands modern workloads.
Instead of paying
commercial licensing fees,
your organization can
just now run Kubernetes.
Instead of maintaining a Pivotal
Cloud Foundry environment
and a cloud
architecture, with Kf,
you can save costs
by running everything
on a single platform.
But don't take my word for it.
Be sure to watch CoreLogic's
Cloud Solution Architect Jeff
Henry's Google Next talk,
which details their transition
to the cloud using Kf.
In it, you'll see how CoreLogic
replatformed 10,000-plus Cloud
Foundry applications using Kf.
You'll learn how this tooling
minimized developer disruption
by retaining the Cloud
Foundry experience, while also
standardizing platform
automation on Kubernetes.
And you'll review the
assessment and migration
tools CoreLogic used to
automate and accelerate
their migration to Kubernetes.
To wrap up, I want to point
out three use cases that
make Kf an excellent
tool for platform admins
to quickly modernize
their infrastructure
using Kubernetes.
One, to help you develop
a migration plan,
you can use the kf
command-line tool
to assess your current
Cloud Foundry environment
and create an inventory of all
the Cloud Foundry resources.
Two, you can also use Kf
as a drop-in replacement
for the Cloud Foundry CLI
to keep the same developer
workflow as before.
Just swap cf push for kf push
and you should be good to go.
And finally, at
runtime, Kf can be
used to provide an abstraction
layer over Cloud Foundry
so that Cloud Foundry
applications can
run on Kubernetes unchanged.
So this is my call to action
for any Cloud Foundry customer.
If you're running an open
source or any commercial version
of Cloud Foundry, try Kf.
It's a bridge to
getting your application
running on modern tooling
like Kubernetes and GKE,
which is the number one managed
Kubernetes distribution.
So to get started, check out
the documentation listed below.
The Getting Started guide
is especially lovely
if you want to explore
the tool for yourself.
And you can always reach out
to the project stakeholders,
whose emails are listed
in the description below.
That's all for now.
See you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]